pêchez le homard en face de Matane ou
plus en amont encore dans le
Saint-Laurent peu de gens y aurait cru
et pourtant ça pourrait devenir une
réalité d'ici quelques années à peine
alors que certaines espèces sont en
difficulté à cause du réchauffement du
climat les homards eux grandissent plus
vite et les stocks se déplacent mais
reste à voir si une pêche commerciale
dans ces secteurs encore inexploités
peut être durable
[Musique]
le soleil se lève sur ma table au Quai
des Pêcheurs un équipage de la Première
nation ou à lasto Quick Wassim Bego
s'apprête à larguer les amarres
ouais je la détache cette première
nation connue jusqu'à récemment sous le
nom de maléite entreprend une cinquième
saison de pêche expérimentale au homard
loin des secteurs où se crustacés et
traditionnellement pêché au Québec
on exploite le homard en materni et en
haut de Gaspésie depuis 2018 ce sont des
fonds de pêche qui n'ont jamais fait
l'objet d'une pêche commerciale donc ce
sont des permis expérimentaux
l'objectif de cette pêche est de
comprendre comment le réchauffement de
l'eau affecte les homards
autrement dit c'est une pêche dirigée on
déploie les engins de pêche dans des
endroits déterminés à des profondeurs
précises pour récolter les données afin
de mesurer l'abondance
distribution et productivité vous
commencez à avoir des bouées au large un
peu
de gros
on doit mesurer chaque Hommer à chaque
levé dans chaque casier donc les homards
sont mesurés au millimètres près avec un
gabarit qui arrondit un peu cette mort
on veut savoir si c'est une productivité
locale ou si on parle seulement d'un
environnement où la productivité ne
serait-ce que passage migratoire
les changements climatiques touchent
déjà plusieurs espèces du Saint-Laurent
pour ce qui est des homards les données
démontrent que la température de l'eau
dans les profondeurs où ils vivent
varient d'année en année mais ce qui est
clair c'est qu'on y observe bel et les
biens une tendance au réchauffement qui
vient perturber leur air naturel de
distribution
le homard a une distribution de plus en
plus septentrionale et de plus en plus à
l'ouest il y a pas si longtemps que ça
de voir du homard à pointer au pair
c'était inconcevable aujourd'hui le
homard a pointé au pair c'est fréquent
il y en a même au Bic jusqu'à Trois
Pistoles c'est une bonne nouvelle
nous en profiter
mais avant d'en profiter il faudra que
les résultats de la pêche expérimentale
permettent la mise en place d'une pêche
commerciale durable dans ces nouveaux
secteurs
c'est de mesurer la capacité de la
ressource à supporter un effort de pêche
commercial la première nation accorde
beaucoup de fierté et d'importance aux
pêches commerciales ce sont nos employés
membres de la nation qui pèsent ce sont
nos employés qui prennent les données
partagent tout ça avec le ministère des
pages océans donc un élément de fierté
de participer à tout le processus
expérimental quatre femelles avec œuf
ça c'est plus important dans le fond là
c'est les homards femelles avec des œufs
ça c'est des reproducteurs c'est pas
toutes les femelles qui font des œufs
fait que selon les remèdes
35 de ces femelles homard qui porte des
œufs n'ont pas été remises à l'eau elles
se sont plutôt retrouvées dans un
laboratoire à l'Institut Maurice
Lamontagne le femelle de peu près 600
pêche et aussi en Canada Imène des
recherches afin de comprendre comment le
réchauffement de l'eau affecte la
croissance des homards et quel impact
ces changements auront sur les pêcheries
les données qu'on va recueillir ici ça
va nous permettre vraiment de peaufiner
notre compréhension du développement des
jeunes stades qui eux ont une grosse
influence sur le temps que ça prend
avant que les homards vont atteindre la
taille commerciale qui sont capturables
pour la pêche
donc là on vient prendre des mesures sur
les yeux qu'on a récolté chez nos
femelles aux morts qui avaient des
masters donc on va venir mesurer en fait
les yeux embryonnaire puis établir un
ratio à partir de ces mesures-là
va nous donner un indice de l'état
d'avancement du développement
embryonnaire
david drelet et son équipe utilisent un
laboratoire unique qu'ils ont construit
eux-mêmes ce système leur permet de
manipuler à leur guise la température de
l'eau dans 60 bassins indépendants
ils peuvent ainsi créer n'importe quel
régime thermique entre deux et 32 degrés
Celsius ce qui leur permet d'analyser le
développement des embryons des larves et
des juvéniles de homard la grosse
contribution ne se proje là c'est la
précision avec laquelle on est capable
de d'établir le lien entre la
température et le développement
normalement les expériences se font à 2
3 ou maximum 4 température mais nous
avec notre système expérimental on peut
avoir jusqu'à 60 températures
différentes donc on a vraiment un niveau
de raffinement des courbes que j'ai
jamais été atteint auparavant
lorsque la température de l'eau est
basse le développement des homards
demeure là mais lorsqu'elle atteint les
13 et 15 degrés Celsius on assiste alors
à une accélération de la croissance qui
se poursuit jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive au
sommet de la courbe autour de 21 degrés
ensuite les chercheurs constatent une
diminution extrêmement rapide de la
performance jusqu'à une température
mortelle qui se situe autour de 27
degrés Celsius donc par exemple si les
deux homards qu'on a ont grandi dans les
mêmes conditions à part seulement la
température que variée donc le plus gros
ici on peut voir qu'il y a du muet 6 ou
7 fois durant l'été alors que le plus
petit que grandir dans les conditions
sous optimales lui a diminué seulement
une ou deux fois donc à la fin de
l'année on peut voir que le petit homard
va avoir beaucoup de chemin à rattraper
pour l'année prochaine pour se rendre
finalement à la taille commerciale donc
c'est pour ça que les premiers stades de
vie les stades juvénile ou la croissance
est vraiment dynamique c'est pour ça que
température une influence vraiment
importante sur leur développement
par exemple
oser de la Madeleine il faut compter de
7 à 8 ans entre la première année de vie
d'un homard jusqu'à ce qu'il atteigne la
taille commerciale mais cela a commencé
à changer
mais il y a quelques années il y a deux
étés chauds un après l'autre ce qu'on a
remarqué c'est que le temps
développement pour la planète commercial
avait diminué de 4 ou 5 ans donc
seulement quelques degrés de plus au
niveau de du développement des juvénile
ça peut avoir une influence vraiment
importante sur sur le temps de
développement puis la teinte de la
taille commerciale puis c'est à cause
des effets qu'on voit ici
les scientifiques ont décidé de pousser
leurs recherches un peu plus loin ils
effectuent aussi des tests dans des
bassins ou les homards sont exposés à
des régimes de température variable cela
permet de tenir compte des conditions
climatiques changeantes observez à
travers l'horaire de répartition en
milieu naturel de la conteste américaine
jusqu'à chez nous
donc on va aussi répliquer en
laboratoire différents profils de
température qui viennent de partout à
travers l'air de distribution du homard
de Virginia Beach juste ici à l'estuaire
puis avec des modèles mathématiques on
va essayer de coupler les deux donc de
partir de la courbe mesurée à
température stable pour faire des
prédictions de différents niveaux de
variabilité de température
est-ce que tu pourrais me montrer les
photos du développement pour le bassin 2
s'il te plaît bien sûr ici
le stade 3 on commence à avoir les
points
tous les processus vont se passer plus
vite la croissance va être plus rapide
mais ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'on va
être capable de le quantifier puis
d'amener des outils à la gestion pour
savoir à quoi s'attendre tel ou telle
année
le 21
sur le Saint-Laurent ceux qui réalisent
la pêche expérimentale vont de surprise
en surprise en plus de constater que les
populations de Omar se sont déplacées
ils peuvent maintenant dire que cette
ressource est de plus en plus abondante
il y a deux ans on a débarqué 2000
livres de homard en 10 semaines c'est
très peu on était presque la risée sur
les quais mais l'année suivante de 2000
passer à 12000 livres dans les mêmes 10
semaines c'est beaucoup plus sérieux
donc le homard devient de plus en plus
abondant des beaux morts de belles
qualités à coquille dur solide une chair
délicieuse
pour une somme de 9 cases
c'est que ce sont des fonds propices des
vraisemblablement capable de supporter
un effort de pêche commercial et d'en
faire rayonner l'activité économique
partout dans la région
un avis que partage le chercheur David
dreletcherie du homard viable dans le
Saint-Laurent d'ici quelques années je
pense que ce qui nous attend dans
l'estuaire puis dans le golfe du
Saint-Laurent dans le nord du golf de
Saint-Laurent c'est probablement une
augmentation de la pêche donc on va voir
des stocks qui vont être plus productifs
il y a des belles années de pêche au
bord aussi pour tout ce qui est la
Gaspésie les Îles de la Madeleine mais
les problèmes se retrouvent beaucoup
plus au sud donc dans certains endroits
si on voit les températures estivales de
23 24 25 mais ça c'est détrimental pour
le développement des homardons ce qu'on
voit c'est un déplacement de l'heure de
distribution plus vers le nord dans ce
contexte la pression est forte pour
ouvrir une pêche commerciale au homard
dans de nouveaux secteurs du
Saint-Laurent
mais dans les pêcheurs que les
chercheurs savent qu'il faut agir avec
prudence pour s'assurer de protéger
cette précieuse ressource en fait la
pêcherie de homard c'est la pêcherie qui
est la plus importante au Canada qui
rapporte au dessus de 1 milliard de
dollars par année juste en débarquement
tout information qui nous permet de
mieux gérer cette pêcherie là des
impacts bénéfiques pour l'économie pour
les emplois puis pour la gestion saine
de la ressource aussi reste à savoir si
dans un effort de pêche commercial
est-ce que c'est abondance là va être
récurrente est-ce que la pression de
pêche va permettre un prélèvement
continu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]